The Calabar burrowing python
might be the toughest snake on earth
It has incredibly thick skin
that is very resistant to punctures
These snakes have an odd shape--
their heads and tails look very similar
This is thought to be a tactic to fool predators--
when threatened,
the Calabar hides its head and offers its tail
Calabar snakes grow to about 1m in length
When compared with 13 snakes of about the same size
They had skin that was 15 times as thick
On top of this numerical superiority,
the deep dermis is composed of neatly arranged collagen bundles
-- more like the tough dermis of a white rhino
than its thin-skinned snake brethren
The hinges between the Calabar’s scales
and its body are also specialized
Hinges are thought to be useful for flexibility
but could be a considered a weak spot
in a snake's armor
The Calabar’s hinges are much smaller than others'
This adds up to these snakes being resistant to punctures
When tested with hypodermic needles
and a force transducer
its skin was orders of magnitude harder to pierce
than any other snake tested
Why might a snake need such a tough hide?
Other snakes that have shared behaviors
like slithering through leaf litter
and tails that look like their heads,
don’t have such a durable dermis
But the Calabar has a hunting habit
that might be the answer
The team thinks the snake’s armor evolved
to ward off bites from the mothers of the baby rodents
it preys upon.
Even with all these anti-puncture adaptations,
the snake’s skin remains flexible—
a combination that already has piqued the interest
of a company seeking to make tougher medical gloves
that don’t restrict movement